This week, on Sunday,
Alexey Navalny -- politician,
opposition leader and my father --
will have been in prison for 1,000 days.
Almost three years.
I miss him every single day.
I'm scared that my father won't be able
to come to my graduation ceremony
or walk me down the aisle at my wedding.
But if being my father's daughter
has taught me anything,
it is to never succumb
to fear and sadness.
And I've experienced both,
fear and sadness.
One of the most fearful moments
of my short yet eventful life
was on August 20, 2020.
That day, I woke up
in my childhood bedroom in Moscow.
Like many of us do
first thing in the morning,
I rolled over to the bedside table
and reached for my phone.
I looked at the screen and was surprised
at how many notifications I had.
Twitter, Instagram, Telegram, you name it.
My feeling of confusion started
to slowly turn into a sense of worry.
Alexey Navalny had suddenly fell
unconscious on the plane
and was taken to the emergency
room at the hospital.
My heart dropped to my feet.
Without blinking an eye,
I jumped out of my bed
and ran to my parents' bedroom
to tell my mom that I was able to look
after my younger brother, Zahar,
while she was away.
But by then, she was already
at the airport.
The plane on which my father had collapsed
had to make an emergency landing
in a city in Siberia.
And after two days,
an international uproar
and my mom fighting tooth and nail
to get him out of there,
he was finally transferred to the clinic
called Charité in Berlin, Germany.
There, at the special laboratory
of the German armed forces,
they confirmed that he was indeed poisoned
by a military-grade nerve agent
of the Novichok group.
He spent three weeks in a coma.
And after months and months of recovery,
he went back to work
with the Anti-Corruption Foundation.
(Applause)
Founded over a decade ago,
the Anti-Corruption Foundation
has been doing incredibly important
and dangerous work
of spreading information
and exposing the corrupt nature
of the Russian government.
We've produced over 500 investigations,
helped organize hundreds of protests
in Moscow and run election campaigns.
We provide free legal assistance
to those who, like my father,
have been imprisoned for peacefully
protesting the regime.
We've created a sanctions list of 6,000
government officials, propagandists,
entrepreneurs, various artists
and more people who've supported
and worked with Putin over the years.
And the list works.
Governments all over the world have used
our list when imposing sanctions.
(Applause)
Because Putin and his associates,
they live lavishly.
They own condos in Miami
and penthouses in Manhattan.
They own vineyards in France
and villas on Lake Como.
They buy enormous yachts
and country houses with gold toilets.
They buy private jets to send
their corgis to dog competitions.
Yes, you heard that right.
In 2016, the Anti-Corruption Foundation
had released an investigation
that Russia's deputy prime minister
owned an undeclared jet
valued at over 60 million dollars
and used it primarily to send his dogs
to international competitions.
All of this
while most citizens in Russia scramble
and live on wages of under 200 dollars.
According to independent polling
done by the ACF sociology center,
only 15 percent of the population
believe in Putin's propaganda.
That means that 85 percent
of the population
either opposes the regime,
doesn’t think it really affects them,
don’t follow politics
or simply don't know what to believe.
This is why we ask our supporters,
who are ordinary citizens,
to spread our investigations and news
content to their family members,
friends and loved ones,
because we know that if we can reach
those who are on the fence
or persuade those who have been
brainwashed by Putin,
we'll get that much closer
to changing the regime.
One of my favorite chants
my dad used to do
during the 2011 to 2014 protests in Moscow
was: “One for all and all for one.”
This is a phrase
that we're all familiar with,
but most of us often forget.
Dictators like Putin want us to forget it.
They want us to forget how strong
we can be when we work together.
They want us to forget
how much we can accomplish
when we stand side by side.
Because it is that much harder
for any dictator
to fight an international united front
than each of us individually.
Now you might think to yourself,
"Dasha, why should I care about this?
Geographically, United States
is quite far away from Putin.
Is he really that threatening to us,
or are you just trying
to raise unnecessary alarm?"
And to that, I want to respond
with another thought.
If we don't stand up for them now,
then who will be left
to stand up for us later?
(Applause)
Cyber attacks, spreading
of propaganda and disinformation,
meddling in the elections,
bribing your government officials.
This has been and is continuing to happen.
The West, Europe and the United States
have tried talking to Putin.
And where did that get us?
The illegal annexation of Crimea in 2014
and now a full-scale war in Ukraine.
Tyrants and dictators
don't want diplomatic relations.
All they want is power.
I often catch myself thinking
how I shouldn't have gone back
to school that fall.
I should have stayed with my family
while my dad was recovering.
I should have gotten on that plane
with him back to Russia
and hugged him before he got unlawfully
and outrageously arrested at the airport.
That day when he went back,
on January 17, 2021,
thousands of people showed up
at the airport to support him.
When I was younger,
I didn't really understand
how my dad could be
so optimistic about the future.
He was constantly threatened,
arrested, followed.
Our family would be followed
by men dressed in all black,
wearing baseball caps
and a ridiculous-looking fanny packs
when we would go to the cinema.
(Laughter)
And after a while, my dad decided
to make a game out of it.
Whenever we would get on the subway,
we waited until the last moment
and quickly got out of the car
right before the doors closed,
so that FSB agents were left behind.
(Laughter)
A unique childhood experience.
I think one of the main reasons
for my dad's success
is that he has always been incredible
at channeling his emotions
into hard work and motivation.
He wouldn’t get sad,
and he was certainly never afraid.
Instead, he would get fired up.
Fired up because he saw a group of ex-KGB
corrupt criminals come into power
and destroy his country.
Seeing that motivated him so much more
to work that much harder to stop them.
And that is what makes a true patriot.
Of course I understand
that, first and foremost,
the change needs to come
from within the country.
And that is precisely why,
knowing all the risks,
my dad went back to Russia 996 days ago.
Because he simply couldn't not go back.
My dad is an incredibly courageous
and selfless man,
and I can only dream
to be like him one day.
He doesn't run or hide.
And unlike my father, Putin is a coward.
A coward --
(Applause)
A coward who, with his cronies,
can no longer hide from the consequences
of what they have done to my country
and democracy around the world.
And you, everyone who's sitting here today
or watching this online, you can help.
Now.
You, unlike millions [and] millions
of those who have been threatened
and murdered and silenced in Russia,
you have a voice.
Please don't take
your freedom for granted.
Russia is my home.
It’s where I was born.
It’s where I grew up.
It’s where I became the person I am today.
And I will promise you that I will
continue to speak up, tell the truth,
and I will continue fighting until Russia
is a free and democratic country.
Thank you very much, free Alexey Navalny.
(Applause)